all right Ralphie boy what's up this has
been on my mind for like 45 minutes now
what the [ __ ] could Sal and Ronnie
possibly be talking about three times a
day I gotta tell you man Sal has been my
hero I've never thought I'd hear someone
say Sal is my hero
yeah my hero
I know what's going on actually Sal's
been great because Ronny has a sick
relative south has a friend who is a
medical person who is helping out
I called Ronnie the other night I
thought the two are you were blowing
each other I mean like Ronnie's like
such glowing comments I got the same
deal oh my god I always like so [ __ ]
nauseous from hearing about just like oh
poor Ronnie he's down to depending on
Sal once you get the doctor Sal's out of
the equation no he's not the doctor
keeps in touch with him Texas and what's
going on and Sal relays it to me you
know it's so fascinating you've heard of
the old game telephone you know like
imagine he's got a real life-and-death
situation and you're linked to real
medical information is Sal and sounds to
the doctor and then that phone call must
be okay Sal my lifeline my hero what did
the doctor have to say and you know Sal
can't pronounce even a normal word all
of a sudden your lifeline is the guy who
beat off to his aunt [ __ ] you know
it and you know I'm imagining like
Ronnie so I sitting by the phone and
goes oh [ __ ] I'm so worried I'm gonna
call I don't even bother Sal but I gotta
get the medical information out so
Ronnie dials the phone and he's like a
[ __ ] you feel so bad but Sal's my
lifeline I gotta call him and he calls
the phone and meanwhile on the other end
the
Sal is in a room he's nude he's watching
his pals watching as watching men men on
women's faces and drinking it he's
jerking off and now all of a sudden it's
like hello was it a wig pretending to be
a woman goes you know Ronnie I was in
the middle of something very important
Ronnie would you mind if I called you
back in 15 minutes I've got a matter
here did some things at the pond this
rock-hard dick is now soft did happen
when I did call mrs. Luce and I gotta
get back to you I can't talk right oh
yeah
the way that is more on with your only
lifeline to the doctor and the doctor is
dr. pests who waits his 15 minutes and
at this point he's dialing the phone
he's like god I don't want to bother Sal
but I've got to find out about my loved
one I gotta find out if my loved one is
okay he's the only connection I have to
this doctor and he's dialing the phone
and at this point sounds like vaping and
coming into his own pouch you know he's
got that foreskin there he doesn't want
to make a mess and there it is and then
Ronnie's on the phone Sal can you please
give me information and then Sal
interprets the medical information that
Ronnie's been so desperate for for the
last couple of hours there he is my hero
Sal
I'd rather [ __ ] jump out a window